Hello.
We are live.
Cool.
So, here's the plan uh for today.
Hey, Beep. Welcome.
my chat box.
Yes, can hear.
Okay. Um,
we're going to continue on kernel
benchmarking today. The goal is to get
we can profile kernels.
Yeah, the goal for today is to get
correct uh kernel benchmarks for just
about everything
and
uh to hopefully start using those to
really understand exactly where we are
leaking perf for everything. That is the
goal.
And we wrote this
uh this one yesterday.
I'm going to get one additional window
open for this I think.
puffer lm when no puffer lm.
If I solve RL and LM are still done by
then, then maybe we do some things. But
honestly, most of that stuff is just
hardware bound as far as I can tell.
Let's actually we'll take this. We'll
put this here. We'll put this here.
Okay. So, we have our kernels.
Uh, we also have
So first thing is going to be to check
mismatches. Here we have
2.29 bill.
This actually matches pretty much
exactly here.
So that's nice.
And then we have log co some values.
This gives us one bill. So, okay, right
here already. Right, this one is at 1.8
bill for forwards
and then way faster also backwards.
So, uh, one of these timings is messed
up. One of these timings is definitely
messed up. Uh, let's go check. It's not
the torch wrapper because the torch
wrapper is very closely matching.
We can go check the shapes real quick on
this.
my super maven binary.
Thank you.
Okay. So in log cos and values here.
Oh, you know what? Uh this one gets
benchmarked.
This gets benchmarked under no grad,
right?
Let's go check on that if we're doing it
correctly.
Yeah. So, I actually have the whole
timing set up quite different here,
don't I?
Yeah, I have it set up for forward and
backward.
Why is backwards C++ uh so so these are
poorly named right now but that is my
custom kernel versus uh it's not C++
versus torch it's the C++ torch API
without a custom kernel. So all this is
essentially saying is that my kernels
are actually good and make a huge
difference. I need to rename a bunch of
stuff, but I also have to fix all of our
tests.
Hey Jess, we're finishing the uh kernel
benchmarking
It's actually kind of funny. Um, it
looks to me like our benchmarks in torch
are not amazing. Like these can be
better.
Okay, backward.
updated opinions on Opus and Cloud Code.
Uh,
where's the tweet? I need to write a
full article.
TLDDR though, it's League of Legends.
Opus is just League of Legends. It's a
great game. Community shares the same
two brain cells.
Okay. So,
is this what car path is on? No, man. I
don't know what the hell he's on.
That tweet was flagged. That tweet was
some drugs.
I hate to tell you, man, I've never
played the original Starcraft. Actually,
I've never played Starcraft 2 either. I
was not an RTS guy. Um,
the thing is none of the models have
good users. It's like
uh there's yet to be a good interface
around language models that doesn't like
you need an interface that encourages
you to think and not to be
intellectually lazy
other options. I I don't this is the
thing that like okay this is the key
thing that like surprises people. I
actually don't think that it's going to
matter this model versus the other
model. The thing that matters here is
the uh the context and the looping.
And yeah, basically the context and the
looping
as well as the token speed for a model
this size.
Articles coming out when I get around to
writing it. Simple as that.
The way that I do work, I have like the
top three to five things in my head that
I know I need to get done and I just
work on whichever one I feel like
working on any on any given day.
I try and make an interface. The thing
is like
you basically I think you'd have to
rewrite flawed code essentially. Um
so there's a chunk of that there's a
chunk of what is in here that is usage
of the model that you would need to
duplicate exactly and then there's a big
chunk of like how it's integrated. I'd
like to see I'd definitely like to see
versions of this that are directly in
your uh your terminal editor cuz first
of all, this thing eating up um eating
up half my screen is kind of sucky. So,
I definitely like to see a version of
this just lives natively in Vim or
whatever. You definitely don't need a
fancy IDE for this, by the way. It can
totally just live in Vim or in whatever
text editor you have. Um,
you know, it's possible that it might
want to have a sidebar, might want to
like just be able to
like have ghost comments or something.
There are like there are a few things I
could see with it. I in my mind though,
like this is not the most important
problem in the world, right? Like
I'm not going to stop doing Laurel to
work on chat interfaces.
And the reason for that is I think a
vast majority of the users just want to
be lazy, right? They just want to be
lazy and stupid. So I don't think it's
like if you just made the better
interface suddenly you'd have everybody
using it. I think you'd get a pretty
small minority of users who say, "Oh
yeah, this is actually way better."
Wait, Cella, since when the Since when
is CarPathy had an LLM company?
though. Actually, we don't care about
this too much. So, we can be a little
lazy with this because we're going to
end up throwing this whole this file was
going to get thrown away.
Yeah, this file is actually just getting
thrown away once we have our full test
done. Like, we don't need the Python
version. It'll just live in C++.
End goal for the week week is a long
time my guy. I don't know what the goal
is for the week. Um
uh for the day though is to have kernels
correctly profiled, benchmarked
and
uh start to get some insight over where
our time is being wasted.
Yeah, I don't think Carpath is selling
anything. I don't think I would. Carpath
is the last guy I would um like the
guy's completely genuine. I don't think
there's any deceit like around that
dude.
And I'd be very careful with who you
throw those accusations at actually as
well because like you definitely there
are a few people that spend their whole
lives like explicitly not doing that and
losing a lot of money for their honesty
and he's one of them.
Nvidia. So I saw something vaguely. I
nothing looked super cool there yet
though.
I know. Puffer contracts are open.
Nvidia
as opposed to any other problem. uh this
is an area of AI that I can make 10,000x
better in roughly three years without
needing a ton of resources or GPUs that
is going to be like widely applicable to
a ton of areas of industry and core
science research and also will just be
awesome and be the easiest and coolest
way for hobbyists to get into the field
as well. Um, there's just this thing
just does everything.
Like there's nothing remotely close to
RL for this
68.
Okay, look. Now we match, right?
Uh, backward SPS doesn't match at all,
but let's check.
Okay, this matches perfectly. Backwards
actually pretty close.
541.
Why is view scan is way faster here?
Maybe this is different else.
PO law is also screwy.
Interesting. Let's go check the the
numbers.
just in case the uh SSH connection
drops. I'm making a quick commit
is rich from his open AI shares. Well,
that should mean that he doesn't need
more money and can just go work on
whatever he wants, right?
So, I'd imagine he's building Eureka
because he thinks it's actually
genuinely good.
Do you care about money? Yeah. It's not
the only thing I care about, though.
Like I'd rather have a bunch of awesome
labs than a yacht, but
and have a nice house and stuff
obviously.
scan
B T + one and H
B T + 1 512
so the very first one that doesn't match
is
log colon values
right
14.
Okay. So
let's just let's uncomment this.
We'll just do
Does this have um TF
whatcham call support?
That's only for matrices. That shouldn't
matter.
It's kind of crazy though because even
though I'm not like consistently running
the cards, I'm really only like running
a ton of experiments uh when I'm doing
like that type of work. So certain
blocks out of the year, it still pays
for itself because the uh the rental
cards are just so ludicrously
overpriced.
Well, actually I the one exception I
could see is if you're just like doing a
project with
Well, but then it wouldn't be more
productive.
I don't see how you get those two
simultaneously.
four.
Yeah.
was actually does Ford match everything?
It doesn't match everything, right? Log
[ __ ] x
Look, the peer pressure should not be to
not think.
It's not like people are getting better
at their jobs. Like the people who are
being lazy and not thinking are just as
worthless as they were before.
It's very simple. Do you want to apply
effort and think and learn things or do
you not? That's the only decision you
have to make.
Like you should see the difference
between what I'm doing now and what I
was doing the first stream. Like I
picked an application where these things
would be very effective. I'm using it in
a way that where I retain full and
complete control over every possible
level of it. Right? And I'm mostly using
it to uh cut out the [ __ ] time of my
job that's meant like that's spent
fighting
like undocumented torch stuff and like
uh conflicts between the C++ version and
the Python version or between that and
food integration like
They weren't doing anything anyways in
like most of the fang employees are not
doing real work.
They actually the problem is when you
hear that like actually talented devs
laid uh devs get laid off is that their
managers can't actually tell which ones
are doing work and which ones aren't.
Like look, the truth of it is it's never
been easier to learn CS than now.
Um, you've never had the same number of
people as now openly admitting that
they're essentially stupid and worthless
in the field. So like there's a lot of
competition, but most of it is
incredibly low quality. So if this is
somehow still an excuse to not bother
trying, then you weren't going to try
anyways.
It's very simple.
This does have retain graph.
But what is the mutable grad thing? See,
I don't understand what is torch mutable
grad. Is this even documented? I've
never seen this before.
They're not vanishing in.
That's the thing. They're not like no
more than on normal economic cycles.
Okay, so this is supposed to be the same
thing
apparently.
It could be the warm-up times.
Uh, it could definitely be the warm-up
times.
Oh, yeah. This is Okay, there's a
different thing.
Oh,
1.38 bill.
Yeah, this is way closer, right?
Okay, so 2.29 1.78 1.38.
Good.
479 12279
12. Good.
Uh, this view scan off. I think this one
still mismatches.
Yeah, this one still mismatches. Cool.
Uh, so these first three are correct
now.
Inconsistent. Man, it's really obnoxious
how like it's so easy to mess up
profiling with torch. It's so easy to
mess it up.
My bad.
Steve. That's just economic cycles
though.
Like anytime there's a new super
valuable tech, right, that has any sort
of learning curve, even if it's a very
light one, people get super overpaid for
a while on it.
like the approach is the same
regardless. It's just like learn stuff,
build something worth a damn simple
beginner tips for profiling with torch.
Oh man, it's like there are so many
things. So
the torch profiler has a ton of overhead
and lies to a lot. it doesn't give you a
sufficient breakdown. Uh, MSYS is good.
You want to cut out Python overhead as
much as possible. Uh, CUDAPs are nice if
you can do that to cut out overheads.
You can actually see kernel times. Uh,
if you want standalone kernel times and
sis will give them to you. Man, it's
there's not even like a a three tips
thing. It's just there's so many sources
of overhead and so many things in
between you and figuring out what the
hell is actually taking up time. Like
I've been essentially doing this on
puffer for a month. What kind of kernels
are you benchmarking here? Um there are
a couple gating kernels for Mingru and
then there's uh one fuse scan operation
and one fused loss.
They're not big kernels. Uh they're
mostly seek level and elementwise
kernels not m not not include uh not
including map balls uh that just need to
be fused because our nets are small.
Some people get lucky. Some people make
their luck, right? And then some people
work really hard and get screwed over.
But there's nothing you can do about
that. So,
not a good reason to just not bother.
B, T and H, right? And then we do fuse
scan on this. Logs.
What if I do this one?
Cuz this is supposed to be way fast,
right? Test view scan
slow celestar
profiling and lost my evening.
Yeah, but the thing is like
coyote, your env is just going to be
slow,
right? That's the bottleneck guaranteed.
If you stick around and you kind of look
through a lot of the materials we have
here, we have all sorts of stuff on
building fast ends.
It's really a nice um nice way to
combine some pretty chill uh high
performance systems dev and like
low-level game dev and then also doing
RL stuff.
The thing with the like CS degree is
like
it really doesn't teach you how to be
useful.
It's kind of it's almost uniquely shitty
in the sense that like the degree is so
far removed from what is actually
important for your work. Um
I don't know. There's several things
that are just messed up with CS in
general, like the teaching of it. But
I mean, actually building stuff is
pretty awesome.
That's fine. But that's not going to fix
it. Actually, that could it be
alignment?
That would be Jen, right?
Yeah, we're expecting it's still Jen,
but it could be alignment. Maybe.
That'd be so weird. I doubt it.
Yeah, it's the old, you know, uh, what
is it? Like hard men make easy times.
Uh, what is it? Hard men make soft
times, soft men make hard times.
Whatever the hell it is.
Oo,
that's actually a good catch. I missed
that.
Yeah, I just totally missed that.
it is overhead in the torch buns. I just
didn't see that
Let's figure out why this is
lock.
Yeah, I missed this.
Let's try that again.
work on beyond constellation.
Well, this is quite a bit of stuff,
Jess. Like kernel's got to be fast,
net's got to be stable, experiments got
to work, all the end bindings got to
work. Um, you know, we just have it like
testing on breakout now. Vex's got to be
tested. There's a lot of crap in this.
But then yes, the idea is once we figure
out the whole of the C++ back end, then
mostly I get to run experiments and fix
up a constellation.
It's just a ton of work. I don't know
what else to say. It's a lot of work.
Hi, George. To hear you out
on what?
I actually can't really comment too much
on the overall architecture of Torch.
Um, I haven't even gotten to that level
of complaining yet, right?
The only thing I can say is like the
implementation of each individual thing
is way way longer than it needs to be.
And uh they're putting too much stuff in
Python native instead of putting it into
the C++ with bindings. And then they're
also using way too much like C++
everything.
Um a lot of this stuff could be I don't
know.
That one is more subjective. The other
ones are definitely the case though.
Okay, so now we got the fused loss 732
and 1.5 bill
Opus way better Phoenix
way better completely
Okay. So this is
to bill.
And
oh, let's check the torch one.
Oh, look at that. So you're dropping
here quite a bit of PF.
So the four doesn't match, but this
actually the backward matches the torch
one.
So let's go check on this.
Go check on this.
The torch one doesn't match.
I think the torch one matches.
So, now we got to test this thing.
Well, we'll double check this and uh
then this will be the last one and then
we'll be able to do some analysis. I'll
be right back. Let me use a rest room.
And what time is it? 12:47.
I'll get a refill on my tea as well.
>> Few minutes.
Okay,
that took a little longer than expected.
All right.
So now we have what we have
1500500
uh 1500.
Yeah, it's just a forward pass here is
all we have left to uh sort out. Now
this is the
this is the forward pass of our torch
wrapped kernel.
And this is also the forward pass of our
torch rack kernel.
So
it should be right here.
Just
pliers grad
test kernel
Is this going to be the right D type
actually
or is this going to be like doubles or
some [ __ ]
Well, no wonder these don't work.
Now I know why this doesn't work.
brain is not raining. Uh, what am I
doing? I was looking at the
fused.
Where's my torch function?
It's here, right?
And I have these as floats.
I see.
Interesting. Right.
Now you're calling fuse PO loss.
I'm calling it with floats directly.
I'm actually then I'm confused how this
even freaking works.
Gotcha.
That's it. Okay.
all right. Now we match.
Uh there's a little bit of overhead, but
otherwise we match.
Now, I would like to do uh there's a few
things I'd like to do here.
This is brain dead work. This is not
outsourcing thinking.
Get which ones?
Mr. Gate.
referring to an LM.
Yeah, this is so much nicer.
Well, because like I'm literally this is
me. I'd have to go spend 10 minutes
fussing with constants, right?
And then I get to stop thinking about
what I'm currently thinking about in
order to fuss with constants.
And like what I'm currently thinking
about is okay um if we can get these
batch sizes to match our train setting
right then we should be able to just add
up the microsconds per call.
We should be able to just add up the
microsconds and that should get us close
to our real timing. And if it is, we'll
have a lot of confidence.
great game.
Um, so like you can actually use the
models to dramatically improve work
output not on everything on certain
classes of problems. Um, and you can do
it in a way that where you learn the
exact amount that you would learn
otherwise, where you're producing pretty
much the exact code that you would
produce by hand, uh, while all while
being substantially more enjoyable.
However, the way that everybody was
suggesting that I use these models and
pretty much everything else that
everybody was telling me, everything
else that everybody was telling me was
complete and utter [ __ ]
So
Yep. This is exact. See, this is the
exact code I would write.
Community will get worse, more worse
with time. Uh, it'll get better and
worse. It'll get bigger and some people
will decide that they want to use their
brains and other peoples will decide
that they'd rather replace them with
claws.
like pretty much any reasonably smart
person can learn um can learn a lot of
the stuff I'm showing off here. There
have been a few cases where I've seen
like, you know, some people that
actually work very hard and they sadly
just don't possess the intellectual
capacity for um for it. But most of the
time, you know, when you have somebody
who's reasonably smart, they actually
and is willing to put in the effort and
learn, um, they actually can get to be
quite impressive.
It's actually a pretty good analogy with
League because it's like the game is
good, but it's also kind of designed to
piss you off.
So, you know, the models are good, but
they're also kind of designed to make
you totally lazy. So, it's like not
totally your fault, even though it
mostly is.
It's one of those
best paper in self-supervised RL.
It isn't RL.
There's no value function.
Uh you can do RL without a value
function.
You can actually like it's very weak but
you can have RL without a value
function. You can't have an uh you
cannot have RL without interaction.
I don't know. This has been something
that's been like fairly obvious to me
for a long time, but it's one of the
main things I always run into in
discussions with people. Like most
discussions of like is this like is RL
this or is RL that is just a fundamental
misunderstanding of the purpose of a
definition. Like the purpose of a
definition, especially when it's a
taxonomy of some sort, is to draw a
clear boundary around the thing that
you're referring to. Therefore, you
should heavily bias definitions towards
being something that is like very clear
to understand and has a clear boundary.
Right? So defining RL uh as learning
through interaction, it is the simplest
definition that captures the thing that
we want. Definitions that are based on
like intricate mathematical descriptions
are far less helpful. They're far less
easy to understand. Um they're far
easier to fudge with edge cases. So when
I say that like RL is learning through
interaction, no interaction is no RL.
It's because this is the best definition
for RL.
This is the thing that describes RL in
one line. Therefore, this should be the
definition of RL.
And I'm not even like doing anything
revisionist either because if you look
in um if you look in like um Sutton and
Bardau they have this like learning
through trial and error like learning
through various forms of this right
deeper networks rather than shallow.
Uh I've seen some stuff on that but then
Nobody ever bothers to do the flops
comparison or the wall clock comparison.
Designed to make money. If it didn't
replace brains, what would they sell?
They'd sell the exact same thing in a
way that's designed to let you do more
work while still thinking
rather than replacing you entirely.
like the people who are assuming that we
should just hand over programming as a
field or as a discipline to LLMs don't
seem to realize that like programming is
pretty damn well the closest thing that
we have to logic itself. So when you're
saying we should hand over programming,
you're really saying that we should hand
over thinking
and that's atrocious.
It's kind of like the same way like oh
we should hand over art completely as
like we should hand over creativity
that's also important to humanity,
right? It's not the same as saying we
should hand over calculators like to the
machines. It's very different.
without having any link to what the math
term describes. Yeah. High school in
grade nine. What min maths do I need and
how do I speed my learning? Oh, hey,
welcome. Um, grade nine.
If you're very smart, you can do it
quick. Uh, you should probably expect it
to take a few years. You need to have a
like a good first college course in
linear algebra.
Doesn't have to be the math department's
course to be fair. The math department's
courses are quite abstract. It could be
the engineering courses linear algebra.
In fact, I might even recommend that.
Um, but you definitely need linear
algebra. You need to have derivative
calculus, multivariate derivative
calculus in particular. So, you need to
be comfortable with what a partial
derivative is. Uh you don't need to be
super happy taking them by hand all the
time. Though you should at least
understand where uh where all the
derivative rules come from. Um you need
to get comfortable with uh derivatives
applied to matrices. It's a lot less
scary than it looks. It's pretty much
the same as your normal multivariate
calc. Um there are a couple cases where
it gets hairy, but not super common. Uh
you should know that. And let me think.
I mean you should know integral
calculus. It just comes up way less
often except in a few specific classes
of models. Uh pretty much all of
autograd is based on just chain rule for
partial derivatives.
So yeah, I'd say that um I will also
tell you that you are while you do need
some math fundamentals and they are
essential, you are far far more likely
to get bottlenecked on programming
competence. like at least for the work
that I do um people screw up way more
often because they are bad programmers
than because they are bad at math. So
yeah, read my guides. I have a uh a nice
article on my ex account.
This is useful for new people. This will
save you a lot of time. It will probably
take you a while before you can
internalize this completely.
But this article is kind of all of my
best advice in one place. So maybe read
this every month or every couple months
while you're learning. And then this is
for RL specifically
and it's just on my handle here. All
free content.
There you go. And best of luck. We also
have a ton of open source stuff in
Puffer if you want to try your hand at
that.
Yeah, I missed the question originally,
Jess. I always reply to those.
Puffer, your only source of income?
Well, I mean, it's it's my company, so
yeah.
Right.
This stuff is open source, but we still
do stuff professionally for companies.
We do um high performance custom
simulations for a variety of domains. So
companies can hire us to build them a
SIM that is speced for high throughput
RL and then to plug it into Puffer Lib
and get them baselines and stuff.
Okay, let's see.
Let us see if this works.
and grade nine is a great time to get
started. That's around when I did as
well. Maybe I did grade 10.
It's gotten a little easier though since
then. There were way fewer resources
available back then.
I've pretty much been doing
I'd say I've been doing something that
actually resembles programming like real
programming since I was 14. And I've
been doing uh something that resembles
real research since I was 16. And then
I've probably been doing real research
since I was 18.
I don't know since when I've been doing
real programming. The bar for that keeps
increasing.
Probably around 18 as well.
Yeah, probably around 18 as well, I'd
say.
So, this gate kernel gives us Few micros
saved.
massively useful.
I actually don't know why the graph
version is slow. We got to look at that.
Let's run the uh let me just compare the
the torch one to just be absolutely
sure.
invasion
Yeah, HCI is kind of annoying because
there are like a lot of really good
people in that space and then there are
also a lot of really bullshitty people
in that space, you know.
Okay. So, 960
1.78 1.43 1.78. Nope, this 1.78 1.2
Yeah, close enough. Pretty close. Uh,
log X479.6.
That's good.
There's actually quite a bit of variance
here, so I wouldn't worry too much. Uh,
backwards. Backwards. Good. and fuse PO
losses 1.4 1.5 down here. These match
with a little bit of overhead. Perfect.
Johnny, I have open AI. Did they
actually do that?
The problem with the labs, the labs have
now gotten big and they've hired to the
point that probably they have, if I were
to like pick people to have dinner with,
probably some of the people I would
least like to have dinner with now work
at those companies, right alongside some
of the people that like I'd have the
most fun at dinner with.
That's kind of odd.
And I don't mean like people that I
wouldn't enjoy having dinner with
because I disagree with them but respect
their views. That's fine. It's like
people who I just fundamentally think
are screwed up in the head and are like
trying to create a shitty future.
right now we now we have these matching
so we can actually concentrate on the
nice new test that we have here
and we get ourselves
this test looks good to me right we have
forward we have forward and torch these
are almost as low as a kernel launch is
expected few micros the C++ it's like
several kernels, several launches worth
of overhead, and then the graph version
is surprisingly not that fast. That's
interesting to me.
That is interesting to me. Okay.
And now we have log cos and values.
We have a good chunk of overhead right
here to look at.
We have a good chunk of overhead here to
figure out.
And
The forward for this is abysmal.
Uh the graph forward being this low is
odd.
Yeah, the graph forward being this low
is very odd.
How long have I been working on this,
man? 2017.
Nine years ago, I think it's nine years
ago.
10 kernels.
Each is tiny.
Oh, wait. Actually, that's a good thing.
They can count.
I thought I had all the functions at the
top of this.
Oh, they're just here. Cool. Uh, that's
weird, but whatever. So, one,
two,
I guess. Is the minus the kernel?
So wait. One, two,
three,
four, five, six,
seven,
eight.
It's like somewhere between 8 and 15,
right?
I think ours are a bit lower because I
saw we have one's fast enough. So, let's
say four.
Yeah, the negatives do add. Okay,
so 14
SD was what was the conclusion from
yesterday's stream?
Uh, I'm using the tool. I'm using the
tools. I'm not using them in remotely
the way I did from the first stream.
Let me use the restroom real quick and
we will figure this out. Uh we got to at
the moment we're trying to figure out if
our profiles for cudigraphs are accurate
and then we're going to do a little bit
of work on like essentially breaking
down the entire time that is spent in
puffer and act and really really
understanding accurately uh where we're
spending all our time. I'll be right
back.
Is it all in a single fuse kernel or
separate? We have both. We have both.
That's what we're actually profiling.
missing any search.
No,
I'm also not using like I'm not using
this remotely the way I was before.
Um, it doesn't matter as much.
I might add a thing later. This thing
actually I don't even know if this has
done any web searches at all today
though, man.
Let me let me figure out what we're
doing here. So,
I actually do like the idea of um
like stuff like Exa. I actually really
like the idea though of having um having
our information fed to a language model
in a format that makes better sense for
the language model.
So I actually in concept I do very much
like those things. Those seem cool
Oh, this is the wrong one.
And this is the wrong one.
That's totally the wrong one.
So, wait. 20.
this one, right?
And definitely you need to rename these
so it's more obvious.
I want to run the command myself.
I want to see it, too.
I mean, we do expect to be hard memory
bound,
That's funny.
That's super funny.
But like, does nobody do the math on
this? Because
what's an H100 cost to buy?
Oh, okay. So, it is two years worth of
rent or two years worth of rent in it.
It's actually it's way worse on the
consumer chips. Like, if you consider
that the consumer chips are like are so
much better for RL, you end up paying
for the thing in 3 months.
New way apart.
The new way apart from trans. What? I
have no idea what you're link to me, my
guy.
Uh, okay. That's like
that's cached as well. Okay,
here since there's no launch overhead to
eliminate.
No idea.
I really don't consume um
I don't really consume a ton of AI
adjacent content because it's my 247
anyways
and I usually don't find it helpful. I
find it usually more more distracting
than anything.
Honestly, even reading new papers is
distracting most of the time because
most of them are wrong.
It's only two. We still have uh four
hours of work to go.
I'd say this has been good progress for
the first third of the stream. Am I
about two hours?
The thing is, you can't quickly spot BS
in papers consistently.
I mean I always look at like do they use
reasonable tasks? Do they have strong
benchmarks? Um are they like treating
wall clock time as as free? So they're
using like unlimited compute for the
task like controlled variables and
stuff. But the thing is like there are
just genuinely papers where all the
signs look right and they're just still
complete [ __ ]
Like there's no way to quantify
fiddliness
in uh in the paper, right? Like a lot of
the time it's yeah this thing worked
because they fiddled with it for six
months and uh the baselines they're
using even if they match the original
ones right they weren't fiddled with for
6 months and every time you want to get
this thing to work on a new problem if
you want those results you have to
fiddle with it for 6 months
there's not really a good way to
quantify that
there are a few authors that I know just
do good work but very very you
consistently.
I think I just ran the same bloody
thing, didn't I?
So we have the same time here, right?
Then we just have to check the graph.
I think you have to actually trace it at
run time.
I'll let it try this, but I think you
have to trace it at run time.
how much inability replicated
reflectment tooling.
Uh it's not that they're faking the
findings most of the time. It's
like there's not a quantification of
fiddliness
trying to clean up my code to be more
readable. Do you prefer bigger function
or multiple smaller?
Uh I actually just I tend to not split
up functions that don't reuse logic very
often.
Like I will my default is I split out a
function when I'm just copy pasting a
big chunk of code or I'm copy pasting a
small chunk of code multiple times.
The reason for that is you actually you
make the code longer unless the argument
to the function is just like one strct
or something. You end up making the code
longer with more functions because of
the signatures. Uh you can screw up arc
order and stuff and signatures. It's
really annoying. And then uh the big one
is that you force me to scroll up or
scroll like you force me to scroll up to
the function to see the actual
implementation of that. and like I can't
actually see it in the context of the
rest of everything.
So I think that like having a max
function length in your head is very
bad. I would not do that.
I will sometimes break things up when
it's just like there's too much to keep
straight in my head, but I definitely
don't approach things like as by default
you need to break up. I actually I
approach things as by default don't
break things up right just top to bottom
simplest way possible.
research was more open source and use
version control.
Uh, research is not that clean, Coyote.
It really isn't.
Think more in terms of polishing. Now,
we've gotten some improvements, some
chest. Uh, I need, but basically, Jess,
what I need to do is I need to chill in
Discord with you for a bit for like an
hour at some point and like just go
through it and see because I haven't
been involved enough in the project and
like it's just I've been busy with this.
Chess is awesome. This is going to be
such a sweet environment for selfplay
and like it's super verifiable as well.
So I like I just need to find some time
to like go through it for a bit with you
is Oh,
Oh, this is weird. This should not be
this shouldn't be the backward. We got
to look at this. Getting busier.
Well, if you're interested, this project
um there could be some professional no
promises, but this project could like is
definitely if it's executed well um on
the level of our professional stuff. If
that interests you down the line
from what I've heard from Spencer, the
chess uh the chess m has been really
good.
Let me go make myself another cup of tea
real quick. Use the restroom and then
we're going to figure out what's wrong
with this kernel. And then hopefully
halfway through the stream, we should
have everything and then we can actually
start tuning stuff. Be back.
Okay. Hello, folks.
Yeah,
I'm proven myself.
>> Yes, of course.
Honestly, I think like high per chess is
much more complex than a lot of the
client ends we build, but they do have
to be done fully
You know, first couple contracts with a
little oversight is fine, but really
requires less oversight over time.
Looking at these profiles while I have
some soup.
Okay, that should not be launching the
backward kernel, right? Why the heck is
that launching the backwards kernel
board graph.
Uh I have no idea why that's in there
actually.
I have no idea why that's in there.
Actually,
have a go look at this while I uh while
I eat a little bit.
How do I lock in?
No, it's uh it's a skill. Focus and
discipline is a skill.
Um, well, the easiest thing to start
with is looking at other areas of of
your life. How uh how is your physical
condition, right? So, I am currently in
the best physical shape I've ever been
in. Um, I'm not a gifted athlete at all.
I just ran a sub seven pace 5K. I've got
a four plate deadlift, pretty decent
bench. um had a major health scare
uh a year ago with pneumonia and I sort
of built back up to that. Uh while I've
been building Puffer, I've done a couple
marathons. I trained and did a 50K on a
hard force. I had a few powerlifting
goals. So like the outside area of my
life
is kind of a another big sort of test of
discipline and discipline is quite
transferable.
So normally
uh I am very happy working on my stuff
for long hours for a period of a few
weeks at a time before I need a break.
And because I have discipline in other
areas of my life,
um it kind of tells me that if I'm not
into my work, something else is wrong.
It's just not my own personal level of
discipline.
But you don't know that unless you
actually have some other area of your
life that requires it. So for me, that
has been physical fitness. And in my
most productive streaks, I typically
have myself scheduled very nicely. You
know, priority on sleep, priority on
good diet, priority on getting good
exercise in, and not too many other
things going on in my life distracting
me.
That is extra extremely helpful. And
then on work itself, I try to minimize
the amount of [ __ ] that I have to do
that just burns me out and maximize the
amount of time I spend on uh interesting
stuff that actually moves Puffer forward
at a good clip because having to deal
with a bunch of [ __ ] that you don't
feel like making progress, that'll burn
you out super quick. Um
know there are a few other sort of
degenerate forms of work that'll burn
you out super quick. Having tons of
administrative stuff will burn you out
super quick.
But generally, when you're making good
progress at a good clip on work you
enjoy, it's easier to pull longer hours.
That's pretty much it.
It's about the most comprehensive answer
I can get you.
I also have a lot of clarity about
around what I'm trying to build as well,
you know.
really the only way to guarantee you're
not going to make it is to not try.
Other than that, that's just like, you
know, super obnoxious tech bro
bullshitting.
Let me get my soup and then we'll focus
on this.
Still kind of hot here. Maybe let's just
do a little bit on this first and then
we'll um you know I'll eat that.
So
Oops. Hang on.
yeah, these should have gotten fused,
right?
Oh, no, it's not. Silly. Hang on.
I think it's just this, right? node app
and it's yeah it's not going to
override. Okay, let's do it again.
Nice and careful. We follow the graph
stats on a graph.
Huh?
I'm now very confused. Oh, wait.
Instance is 50.
Perfect. So these are the warm-ups
And what was the one that was reporting
something weird?
PP. Yeah. Okay. Cool. Now we get it
correctly.
It's the wrong binary before.
Uh, and we have
132 micros
on the launch.
And then we have these nicely
compressed.
Oh, I I see. I explicitly turned that
off.
132 micros
179 in the full forward.
GPU back pressure.
Okay.
It ran faster with Nesus on than not.
Something seems odd about that to me.
Let's finish this first.
Oh, there's just variance. I see. Wait,
no, there isn't.
Yeah.
Okay.
micros.
And then we have a similar breakdown to
before.
135. Okay.
25 micros is very significant at the
moment.
It's the same binary. It's not
compilation.
Okay. I don't know about that theory.
I'm going to test it.
What's this kernel doing? Uh, this is
log cos and values. It is a operation
that is required during training time
for the mining architecture that we're
using as the backbone of puffer.
So it is a
it's essentially just a big fancy
element-wise uh operation and we are
timing our kernel versus just an
implementation of it in torch. If you
implement it naively in torch you end up
with about 14 kernels. Um, and I'm
essentially looking at launch overhead,
graph overhead, stuff like that. We're
trying to get a very, very accurate idea
of where we're spending compute and what
optimizations help and what
optimizations don't.
How do you know what the speed of light
should be on your card? It's not that
fast yet, man.
That's not uh
we're bottlenecked by things that are
not that.
What speed of light?
Um,
so again, this is we're not even yet at
the point where we're optimizing the
kernel. We're basically we're comparing
lift of the kernel to defaults.
Um this there's several quantities we
want to estimate as a result of this,
right? What's the price of an extra
kernel call? What's the price of an
extra element wise op? Right? What's the
price if you fuse an op um of just doing
the computation? There are a lot of
things here.
These are very small kernels, so we're
dealing with like pretty tight timings.
Like saving a microcond probably gives
us almost one full percentage point of
performance.
graph.
Yeah. Still identical.
if I do just profile graph maybe.
Hang on.
Oh no, it's worse.
Yeah, it's actually worse.
Yeah. So, profiling code is the most
important to have correct in your entire
codebase. Um, if your profiling is
wrong, you are screwed.
So, I'd be a little surprised if that
messed anything up.
We do have it in the warm up.
So, actually, that shouldn't be able to
break anything.
92 very bad.
I'm a little bit suspicious of this.
I don't know why you would need this,
but
like this.
four element load for each
overlap these kernels with each other.
Um
I don't think any of them overlap. No,
just from the logs. I don't know.
I mean, I we're really not at the point
where I should just like start
optimizing each individual kernel yet.
We just really need an accurate profile
because I want to be able to sum up the
time
um
of these that's I want to basically
profile these individually and then
compare that to the time of the net
and see if it sums the way that it
should.
This is quite a complicated
um a complicated thing that they're a
part of.
Kind of have to do both the whole
profile and then piece by piece.
I'm trying to think where this could
come from.
You know, like where
where are the possible sources that this
could get gotten introduced?
Okay, fine. You can do this for a bit.
That's fine. We'll try that one.
Let me rerun that in a moment. Finish my
soup first.
Very odd.
That's quite bad.
So many little things that um mess up
your profiles.
God damn it. That did it.
Now it matches
Literally just some warm-up crap. But
then
if I then I let's say I do all of them
little more than fuzzy docks. Um
they're a fair bit more powerful than
that, but you don't want to use them to
replace thinking for sure.
Okay, that actually seems reasonable. We
can try to redo the warm up.
fragmented memory. That's weird. I would
highly doubt that.
That wouldn't make any sense to me.
Oh, warm up GPU.
Yeah, I don't I'm not seeing anything
that could cause this, but it's a very
consistent behavior.
Okay, fine.
We do fresh tens search. That's a good
check.
We do fresh tens.
That shouldn't make a difference, but at
this point, I wouldn't be surprised.
Nope.
Same as before.
Here's a restroom real quick and we'll
figure this out. This bothers
That's a 40 microcond different
profiling.
There's a 40 microcond difference.
Let me take a look at this manually for
a second.
hardware accelerators
and we'll start start making some stuff
like
I mean the main thing is if you know
some lowle dev there's really not that
much to tell
If you know C, CUDA C that runs on your
GPU. If you're used to profiling C, now
you're profiling CUDA. If you're used to
optimizing C, you're now you know you're
just optimizing some CUDA. There's some
more stuff, but that's enough to get
started.
The hell?
Weird.
Multiple streams.
forcing default stream.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, that's a good thing to check.
That is actually a good thing to check.
So, what is slowing? Yeah.
I guess that tells us that graphing is
fine
plain. A graph
has overhead from caching allocator
interactions.
Graph is not designed for dynamic
allocation patterns.
Just a single parameter.
It's about as good as we're going to
get.
And we'll keep the overall warm up cuz
that one did help.
Just get all these. And then this is
pretty much our maximally clean profile.
Okay, this currently sucks, but we don't
actually use this one, so don't worry
about that. This is the one that we care
about a lot.
50 micros
with the graphing.
Okay.
I like this. Let's make a quick commit.
Yeah.
19 seconds solve. Perfect.
Uh, let's go get the old script. We
actually we had a different script that
I just didn't save
here. We can just do like this.
And we want to see the relative timings
of our kernels
and we can see if they match
expectations etc etc.
It's good.
Well, this will actually I think it just
prints everything for us. So, we'll get
to see it.
And hopefully
we finally will have enlightenment.
where are
where are our kernel names?
Oh, there was also the um
was it NVXT?
This has to be true. So, this
potentially Drop a little bit of perf on
our profile.
Do this again.
Oops. Good memory.
Here
Yeah. So, this is uh this is taking a
pretty sizable bite out of Perf with all
these extra device synchronizations.
And the cool thing is now we can
actually see whether this matches the
expectation.
Like we're going to be able to see
uh the tagged regions that correspond to
our kernels of the code.
And let me just go get a command ready
for
Nice.
Oh, here it is. I don't even need the
command.
2.9 ms.
This is 3 milliseconds.
Well, let me go remember. Let's go
remind ourselves what the heck are.
I suppose now what we would do, right?
Um,
So we'll take cudraphs off.
We'll take cudigraphs to be off, right?
and we'll see if we get our kernel
timings
way slower. You see that's way slower.
Meaning that even with our custom
kernels, we still need graphs.
Kind of funny that our um our super slow
version is still sub 30 seconds. All for
breakout.
It's funny.
Colonel's been going. So, we have um we
have very good profiles at the kernel
level. We also have very good profiling
of relevant tagged regions of our
training code. And now we kind of just
need to between the two of those figure
out what remains for optimization
which is what I'm doing now.
And I'm very happy that I have the
kernel profiles as well because the
kernel profiles are way faster to run
than the whole training profile too.
Okay, here's the whole training profile.
We're left you see gigantic mess, right?
And we can see
let's see the overhead. Okay. So
this was um three milliseconds before
and now it's 3.8. So without graphs we
lose a chunk of perf off of this. Uh
this one was 170 before. So this
actually it's twice uh you lose half
your speed
right here.
You lose half of your speed without
graphs.
and everything else is fairly small.
New PB in MMO 3.
Um maybe it'd be cool. I'd say I'd take
it as a bonus. This architecture is not
meant to be like better. It's meant to
be as good and much faster. If it
happens to end up being better, that's
cool.
is this actually does these even add up
to 100?
I guess we can figure out here because
13% is.7
ms.
Okay, so this does not sum to the full
time.
Uh we also have a bunch of
CUDA launch overhead. You see this right
here?
Yeah, this is 2 and 1/2 seconds worth of
launch overhead.
CUDA launch kernel we have 2 seconds
worth of launch overhead. So this is the
major savings is we save a little over
two seconds worth of launch overhead on
this.
Um so now I suppose
well the thing is these times are going
to get magnified right because these are
the timings on
I guess if we think of them as
percentage based timings that it should
still be accurate.
No because these don't sum to 100 do
they?
I suspect what's happening is that these
don't add for some reason.
I actually I don't even know what the
hell this would be. Percent time of
need some You really don't need some
cudens.
Oh,
they do add. Really?
Interesting.
How the hell does this add to No, I'm
I'm not trusting this. I'm going to be
really stupid here. Okay.
Actually, that's going to only get me up
to 90.
So, either I miss something or it's like
90.
Regardless, it's not that far off. It's
fine.
about puffer liib. What do we have here?
Ultra high performance reinforcement
learning development.
Currently we are looking at a bunch of
custom kernels for um the next release
and we are trying to figure out where we
are losing performance on everything.
That is the idea at the moment.
I mean, it's kind of janky
to be doing it like this cuz like
well actually how much higher will the
percentages be
if we do 7
let's see
okay you You know what? Maybe these get
to be close to twice as important.
nope, not on LMS. We do uh we do very
small model RL for specific tasks. It's
all open source and you can play with it
at home. You can literally train agents
in seconds on your laptop if you have
any GPU at all um or minutes on a CPU.
We got tons of these in demo uh tons of
these demos. They run in your browser.
Most of these agents you can train at
home very easily. A few of them you need
a couple GPUs for.
And it's pretty fun because you can get
superhuman agents very quickly. They're
useful in a number of applications. And
we primarily use games in research for
testing.
We're currently targeting 10 million
step per second training, which is um
well agents that are able to uh play the
games at millions of times real time,
play the game, um drive the sim,
whatever it is.
Not games.
I got to go add some credits to this.
Aiden is someone who only uses Python.
Python only doing my IT class.
Um, well, the thing is you can kind of
just train on any of our existing
environments out of the box.
So, you don't really build an agent.
It's not like a language model thing. Uh
so you can train on any existing MS. For
new environments though, we strongly
recommend C. All of our MS are written
in C. It is very simple C, but uh it's
like a hundred times faster out of the
box than doing the same thing in Python
the way we have our stuff set up. So
we do a lot of low-level dev around
here. It's pretty chill low-level dev.
Um, it's a great way to learn stuff and
also do some AI, but everything is very
performance critical. Things need to be
fast. Uh, as we can see by the fact that
I literally stream months worth of time
in this work to make everything faster.
I will fix this in a second. Let me use
the restroom real quick. And then what
we'll do is I think I want to like just
get some better aggregate profiles where
we sum up the total amount of matte time
and like the total amount of cutless
kernel time and stuff
cuz this is not an accurate enough
overview for me right now. I'll be right
back.
uh, that means that we used $100 worth
of credits in
what was that? Three streams. Two and a
half glo.
We're not going to auto reload credits.
Topological research in Java. That's
cool.
We are definitely interested in helping
um various fields of research with this
stuff.
R RL is like is very very very fast
compared to what is out there at the
moment. Uh the current version of Puffer
Lip can train between two and five
million steps per second. I'd say
reasonable like 3 million. The next
version of Puffer that I'm working on
now, we are targeting 10 million.
We have a stable 7 million step already
trying to get 10 million before release.
I think it's doable. I mean, we're going
to see today, I suppose.
group all the element wise kernels up.
Group all the cutless kernels up.
and we should be able to make some good
progress.
I don't think we have that much in um
I think I don't think we have that much
in Matt Mall. I think there's quite a
quite a bit of overhead still.
material science. How do you frame that
as an interaction problem? So, the
dumbest way possible I can think of this
that I did check with a material
scientist and said he said was not
completely insane was just have all the
atoms steer each other steer themselves
around like little cars in order to
maximize the specific property. So all
the atoms just steer themselves into a
configuration and then you have um you
can mathematically check certain
properties like thermal conductivity etc
etc um and just like reward for
maximizing that property stuff like
that.
If you can make the sim really fast and
good like close enough this seems not
completely stupid to me.
There probably way better ways you can
do it, but that's like the first thing I
would think of to do
I mean we can also always do this as a
pre a post process if we have to but
ideally we don't need
Interesting. This is stats
base.
Oh, base name grouping. Okay.
Yeah, this is way better. But
where are my names?
Oh no, that's exactly what I'm getting.
I'm done.
I'm done. Colonel table. What the heck
is that?
Tensor off.
Colonel 2
cutless tensor off.
Cutless gem
I think maybe there's some other
options.
I mean, we can keep this. It's not
Purple
kernel 2 is um
it's a gem right
element wise kernel vector element wise
kernel reduce kernel.
Yeah, that's not
enough. That's enough. That's enough.
I'm good. That's too much.
Let's do
Uh let's do let's try this one real
quick
because this actually might make a
difference, right?
Okay, so we shall see with this. This is
not much faster.
Um, this might just take some of our
element wise crap out though. We shall
see.
And at the very least,
I'll know that this is not the uh the
thing that's taking up time.
We also know, hang on. We also know
um that fusing kernels is massively
better than graphing fernals because the
membran width in this case.
Yeah. You only graph what you can't
fuse.
And this we just did. No crap.
So
still element wise kernel.
Uh this concat actually funny enough is
really slow
douche kernel.
This is three.
This is five. 35. It's like 35% of the
time is just on element wise kernels.
If I graph this,
I actually I think that there's a way to
do this.
I think that there's a way to do this
like how I want to.
Watch this. If I do node node level
right here. Okay.
So I think you still get the node level
profiling
but then I think I can turn profile off
the thing with this.
I can turn this to true and this to
false.
I think this is the this is the uh the
move here.
Okay, so now we are at 6 mil.
So we're only taking a one mil SPF.
We're taking a 1 mil
uh SPS hit presumably for entrop
injecting kernel level information
despite the fact that we're graphing but
this is still way less of a hit than it
would take for disabling CUDA graphs. So
this should give us a much more accurate
profile. You want your profiling runtime
uh profiling speed to be as close as
possible to the real run speed
So this is now within like 15%age of our
action speed
and we'll see if we still have a bunch
of element wise kernels or what.
or if this just crunches names. We'll
see.
Probably takes it quite a while though
without the graph on because it's just
massive.
Okay, here we go. You could ignore the
fact that this isn't working. There are
a couple bugs in the um fuse kernel.
We're just doing it for profiling
though.
It's not that big of a difference. We
just don't want like all the extra ops
in there
Do they give you a reasonable number of
tokens with the uh the monthly plans?
Okay, this is what we want.
Now we need
we want the aggregated version.
And now we have it, right? So
29% is 2.2 seconds. So this is actually
very close to the full profile now.
Increasingly miserably that I just use
the damn API whatever.
Okay. So with everything on
this is what we get. Okay.
This is some overhead.
Uh we are sinking like 9% in the fuse
scan
5%ish in log host and valves 2.2% in
this min group. We've got 30% of our
compute is real compute. These are matt
holes and everything else is kind of
[ __ ]
While it does this, I'm going to check
the optimizer.
I'm reading all code as well and I'm not
really having it like design [ __ ]
either.
Um, what do we want to do here? So, I
think what we want to do
We know that this one is fine.
Two dtype casts
element wise, right? Ratio. Copy. Copy.
Uh the this level of profiling that it
shows here, we can easily investigate
with tags.
So we actually don't have to worry too
much about this.
This goes up to 8 mil. So this is
definitely overhead.
no. Why the hell would like Nobody
should ever install either of those
ever.
Why would you do that?
Okay, so now we got all these freaking
par files
and we're going to do no
them.
does anything change substantially?
Yeah, I don't know.
It's freaking Twitter.
Ignore this.
Wait, where the heck did this compute
just come out of then?
22 is 28%.
We're going to do it the dumbest way
possible. I'm going to take a screenshot
of it.
These flat profiles are the most
obnoxious things I swear.
But it's much Wait, how is this much
faster?
But we're seeing the same kernel
timings.
I'm confused.
Maybe it's copy overhead.
Well, okay. That does not make a major
diff.
Yeah, I know. I haven't updated my
website in a long time.
You either pretend to be doing work or
you are doing real work. At the moment,
I'm too busy doing real work to pretend
to be doing real work.
This is super weird to me that this is
not
Is there like a gem or something that's
up here? Wasn't there before?
No.
Okay. So, that's super odd.
We have the element wise kernels in
there either way.
Oh, you know what? Ah, we don't have the
we don't have the region tags on is the
problem.
Okay, let's try this with the region
tags. Let's try this with the region
tags.
Uh, I think this should be better.
And actually, get rid of this no optim
thing. We'll just do this. Yeah.
buffer five. Um,
it's pretty much it's like curriculum
learning built in at the level of a
trajectory segment. It's related to go
explore style stuff. It's planned. Uh,
there's still a lot to do before we even
get to think about though, frankly.
Okay, I think this is going to be
proper profile.
Build this.
Sometimes it um filters and it I don't
know
the restroom while this runs real quick.
I've been drinking tea all day.
Yeah. The way it works is um it runs for
a while and then you get to see
does not contain any GPU trace data. Oh
yeah, I think it um
break something.
No, it's good. Fine.
So this will give us with substantial
overhead. This will give us region
profiles and kernel level profiles.
It'll show up. Give it a second here.
Oh, your message. I don't know about
that.
Are you typing like ridiculous keywords
that YouTube's auto filtering?
Tries to filter links and like comment
spam sometimes.
Oh. Oh, that one. Yeah. You found the um
my high school website, right? Yeah.
Okay, so So these percentages are
roughly the same, which is what we want.
There's quite a bit of overhead, but
that's expected.
Oh, that Yeah.
here.
I was like
15 or 16 in this post uh this picture.
This is me like trying to train awful
awful comments in freaking mat lab of
all things
on CPU.
Yeah, this is what lack of autograd will
do to a guy.
quite a bit of overhead in these, but
these are still usable.
I mean, it was like
it's a good resume for that age, I
think.
Oops.
Weird.
He's dead.
Respect his weeps.
Putting dev channel. Let's see.
Come on.
Wait.
Ask Joseph
parameterize and difficulty
scale score with difficulty sweet score
just find part of solvable difficulty.
We kind of have this Finn with um
we kind of have this with our maze ends.
It's a little tricky because like
you'd have to be pretty precise about
it. Like is it is this gore going to be
the like largest maze for which you have
a 95% solve rate or like because you're
training on a bunch of different
difficulties at the same time. is the
idea with curriculum learning.
Parameterizable difficulty is definitely
useful though.
It is almost 5. I got an hour and I need
to make sure we make some good progress
here. I want to make sure we have a good
idea today at least of the remaining
bottlenecks. So
half the time is spent in training.
Core network optimizations are likely
the biggest thing.
The heck could 30% overhead be coming
from?
Do we have a um
average time
nanoc?
Ah look at this.
You see?
Wait, if we group them,
it's still there. Okay, cool. So,
the average call time, this is 3.8 micro
seconds.
So, this is pure kernel overhead.
The vectorzed ones
are even faster.
There just a lot of them.
And that is a crazy number of Matt mall
calls as well.
And they're tiny
might be like kind of correct.
It's just a bunch of slides. I think I
might have videos still on there. It's
me attempting to explain things I barely
understand.
I remember spending like hours just
lying on the floor trying to understand
back prop.
It's actually like a pretty damn
complicated thing if it's introduced to
you without the idea of it a computation
graph. Like good luck.
Oh, wait. The key thing here, these are
getting graphed, but they're not getting
fused.
That's the key thing I'm missing.
140 page. So, A Walrus Tale is not 140
page novel. That's a children's book. Do
I have that novel somewhere? I don't
even know if I have the text of it
anywhere anymore.
Yeah, 140 pages plus. Yeah, I was like I
got like I don't know 200 pages into
writing a novel or something
funny.
Do I have
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that.
I think if I remember, I didn't have a
perfect SAT. Uh I lost a few points on
the essay or whatever because there used
to be an essay and then they changed it
so that they no longer had an essay. So,
because of that, I ended up with a
perfect score with the new system. I
forgot about that.
Barely matters. Whoops.
Uh, there's nothing sensitive on there
anyways. It's just the anthropic
credits.
No, that's just the anthropic credits.
There's nothing on here.
Okay. So, here's what we want to figure
out right now. Okay.
So, we have Where's the epoch on this
this bloody thing?
So, 81
8192.
Oh, it's 64 iterations.
So, forward pass, it's 64 iterations.
Um, four layers,
This gives you 58,000
expected matrix multiplications.
Um I believe it's plus you have you also
have 16
during training.
Spanish. My last name is Suarez, though.
I actually did have to teach myself most
of it.
I actually got the the fluency after I
got into college because pretty much
like I had zero free time until I got
accepted and then I ended up with a
spare semester. So, you know, instead of
taking a break or doing something sane,
I uh I decided to study like
was it I think it was three years worth
of Spanish.
There's like threeish years of Spanish
and two years of Mandarin
um in about three months. So that was
cool.
Languages aren't that hard to learn.
They just take some work.
I mean, think about it, right? Literally
every person in that country can speak
the freaking language.
No, it was way better back then, man. I
worked way harder when I was that age
than ever afterwards. But like I don't
know. It's harder when your work is like
this.
the stuff I'm doing now, it's
it's very difficult to work a very large
number of hours and be productive and
also not be like, you know, getting your
mind sidetracked and working on the
wrong thing.
I forgot we have a few more layers.
Fine.
related kernels. I'm trying to just get
the back the envelope here.
And these kernels are freaking tiny.
I mean, if I cared, I wouldn't have it
on the internet. Roger.
I honestly feel lazy by my own standards
most of the time. Like this is only
going to be a six-hour stream.
6 hours of programming in a day is not a
huge amount.
Six hours of debugging CUDA is slightly
more to be fair.
Okay. So this is the number of math
moles we have in here.
I did multiply by seven. So it should be
by seven, right?
* 4
* 7
128. Uh,
it is actually.
It's doing five per update.
Oh, no. It's doing a lot.
Yeah, Muan should be doing a lot of
mouths.
We should check that.
So without Muan,
Easter eggs
on the internet. Um,
Uh, it redirects to my I used to have a
thing. It's not there anymore.
Uh, I don't think there's much else
then.
Do I work for a company? Puffer is a
company.
Puffer is a private research lab. All
the stuff you're you're seeing here is
free and open source, but we also build
high performance RL SIMs for companies.
We do contracted R&D. We do a few other
things.
Let me go double check. Speaking of
which, thank you for reminding me. There
is a client I needed to
message.
Lucid interview.
Oh jeez, that is old. That is really
old.
That is actually before I knew what the
hell I was doing as well.
They didn't really know what they were
doing either, though.
Uh, okay.
So,
here's what we're going to do.
Hopefully this tells us something.
And then if this does if the matt moles
add up then I will believe the rest of
the elementwise operations and
essentially it'll just be like yo you
have too many bloody operations.
That's literally what it is.
Like hey I know that you tried to reduce
the number of operations. You still got
too many. Keep going.
Eight microsconds for Matt Mull's nuts.
I don't still write for fun sadly,
Justin. I did in the past couple years.
I finally started reading a bunch again.
So, pretty much whenever I'm working
out, I also have an audio book. Um, I've
gone through in the last two years
It's probably like 50 bucks or
something. I don't know.
If I'm doing like um a good running
training block, I go through them pretty
quick.
One every week at least.
If I'm not doing as long of uh like more
endurance sessions, a little slower, but
still pretty good.
not vlog.
I don't actually travel a lot, Anesh. I
traveled a lot when I was younger to the
point that I really don't enjoy
traveling anymore. I'm kind of all
traveled out.
Like, I really don't have a huge list of
places I want to go or things I want to
see. I mostly just have a list of stuff
I want to build.
Okay, look at this. 115
128.
10 seconds worth of profile. This thing
took 19 seconds.
That's very close.
115.
What?
But
what? Oh. Um, what?
How? How? Wait. 1.9 seconds for 200k
instances. 8.4
NS each.
Okay. Way fewer in. Okay. They take
twice as long.
okay. Actually, let's do let's do this.
Put this in here.
close and finish and just
maybe I don't know.
I don't know if there's a way to see
those stats.
P plus P.
Yeah,
This cat's actually the fact that that
one opt so much would tell us really
it's just it is death by thousand cuts
so far
too hidden and gate immediately gets
chunked.
output. Getting it to scan.
Could do that.
because we don't even use them after
that. Yeah, we can totally do that. So,
this can definitely this can 100% get
fused. This can 100% get fused into
scan
philistine because I do [ __ ] in the simp
like I do [ __ ] in a really simple dumb
way. and it usually ends up being very
effective.
I don't like intricate, clever things. I
like simple, fast things that work.
I'm going to
let me let me make a couple quick
commits
Oh, that's nothing. Fine. That's nothing
there. Cool. Not losing anything.
This is giving it a little too much
control for my liking.
Um,
getting some good use. Some good use.
Yeah.
It's a soccer player, right? Everybody I
say off sports. Oh, Louisis.
It's a pretty straightforward
modification.
This is actually a You know what?
I'm going to let it do it because I have
a test. This is a very fiddly numerical
piece of code.
I do have a good test for it, though.
I it can do the modules just fine. I
don't know about the kernel.
Okay, this we have to review very
carefully. So this is going to take log
values and state these changes. This is
fine. This is very simple.
Yeah, go this is we will see. This is a
very tricky kernel. It looks very simple
when you look at it. I promise you this
is not simple.
though once if we can get this fused.
Uh I was actually thinking of doing it
like trying that with it because
this type of chrome lab is just really
hard to think about. We'll see.
It's like very unintuitive the type.
Well, I still don't want to give it too
much control though.
Okay, this is fine. Yes, this is fine.
This was not a question though. This is
easy.
The backward function is the same thing.
The only thing that's actually hard, uh,
the launch functions are also easy. The
only like that's that's nothing. The
only thing that I'm going to want to be
very careful with is if I let it touch
this kernel.
That integration is not easy.
Yep. So this is just this is just
recovering buffers
state. These are all fine.
Okay. There's nothing weird here so far.
Um,
we might want to end up like fusing
these values at some point,
but I think for now it's good.
Again,
this is not the this is not the worry
here.
Okay. So, we have
again this this is fine.
All this is is updating some signatures.
Uh there are a lot of signatures to
update because
you have to go through the uh the torch
binds, the torch class interface, the
launch interface, and the kernel
interface.
That is like very obnoxious and tedious,
and it's very easy to make mistakes
doing it manually, but it's not
difficult.
Um now we're at the
Oh, it just went ahead and did the
kernels.
Base
out. Base.
Let's see. Where does it say out base?
Out base. Okay. Same thing
plus t * h.
I don't know if this is works because I
don't know if this is also a guard. This
infinity is a guard on um numerical
overflows. I think it might be. Again,
we have strong verification on this.
This did add an additional pathway. It
does maintain the infinity though, so
I'm more confident in this.
Okay. So, we add grad out and state.
No, we change grad out just T+1 and
state. Okay.
Okay. So this is now um log value per
time step.
and there's the derivative. So this is
messy
but this is what I expect to be here.
In the interest of time
uh we're going to do we're going to take
this and see the numeric check
because this is like directly verifiable
and we actually have three layers worth
of checks. We can apply
two layers of easy checks.
Launch function. Launch functions are
trivial to update.
Yeah. These are just the launch
functions. Okay.
I give this a one in three shot
of not having broken the numeric. Max
and then the puffer update is again
trivial.
Yeah, because this is just a fuse scan
update. This is going to update the
signature. And then this is going to
update the coal to move uh the cat into
the path that is not fused.
It should be like three line update or
whatever.
Yeah. One, two, three. Right.
Move that into there. Delete from the
top.
That's fine.
So, exactly what we expect except
uh I'm not super happy with the
uh the module modifications are fine,
the launch modifications are fine. This
is fine. The kernel we will have to see.
I'm going to intentionally only compile
the
the PyTorch uh version of the test.
Also, this launch. See, like there are a
million places this has to be changed.
This is one of the reasons why this is
good right now because like normally I
would just design a thing so that you
never have to change something in 10
places. There's actually no way around
it with what I'm doing here.
Um
so,
Oh, it actually did. I didn't think it
was going to remember to do this.
Say it must be positive.
Yes.
I didn't think it was going to remember
to do microbench.
That is the correct build command. Sure.
probably doesn't need to run it. I could
run it for it.
Just burn some tokens for no reason.
No. Okay.
Huh?
Yes, that is the correct command. Let me
go do it myself, though. Thank you very
much.
Okay.
Uh I believe those are passing to the
same talls as before.
We will see when we go to do run
training.
Okay. Uh, I'm actually very surprised
that that is stable.
That's actually very very good.
That's actually pretty genuinely
impressive. That kernel change is not
easy. The rest of it trivial. That
kernel change not easy.
profile has to go to
Wait, do we need profile on?
I just need the op calls. Okay. So,
yeah, what we can do for this.
Okay. What we need for this? We just
need end prop.
So, you take a 1 mil SPS hit. A little
less for profiling. Oh, no. Look. Yeah,
1 mil SPS cuz it just dropped the
profiler off right there. Cool. So, 1
mil SPS hit for profiling.
Expect about a second's worth of
overhead for that. Actually
This is also not running the fuse loss
though.
I need to probably do that.
I am curious though to see how much
slower this makes our fused kernel.
Um because presumably
presumably we're going to be able to
optimize the fuse kernel from here.
Ideal case would be fuse kernel is now a
decent chunk of the PF or of the time.
not positive it will be
because we should have gotten about a 6%
boost from that and I don't think we did
right we got a
hard to say
no we didn't get 6% though we should
have definitely gotten at least a 6%
boost
and we're expecting more time in the
kernel Right.
Okay. So, now we need to do
where's the command?
This one.
And I'm actually going to just take this
command before I forget this command.
I'm going to go put this into the sh
file.
Oh, elementwise kernels
are down a little bit.
We kind of need to take the uh the PO
loss out.
Oh, here's fuse scan backwards.
It's over 10% now. Let me go get the
fuse scan backwards.
What do I got? I got 10 minutes left for
this and then I got to go to dinner
um before my family
decides to report me missing or dead.
Yeah, this is does not execute cleanly
at all.
Yo, what's up with my um memory usage?
Uh, how is my why is my memory like
this?
I mean, it should be fine anyways, but
like what the heck?
I don't know how you can even do that,
but whatever.
Okay. So, it's not going to trade now
obviously,
but it will be it will end up being 7.4
mil without the profiler on.
So once we fix this function, we'll be
happy.
Then we'll go look at the
this kernel
and we should actually get something
meaningful out of this. And then that'll
be it for today.
And we'll be able to do more tomorrow or
whatever. Well, I have some client work
to do tomorrow, but you know, you get
the point. Soon
always outputs good ground truth info.
Uh there's limited work where you can do
that.
Okay. Um,
last thing we need
5.9
4.4
I am actually uh I don't know where this
is now
It's funny. I know exactly how you do
this, but I'm going to do it with torch
Okay, this is the data that we have from
today, guys.
So, we actually now have a pretty damn
good understanding
of where we can optimize.
Um, 30% is actually pretty hard to get
like
It's just that the operations are
absolutely tiny.
Okay,
for folks who've been watching, thank
you for watching the uh 6 hours of
profiling Colonels. That's literally
what the stream ended up being. We will
do another six hours of profiling and
optimizing kernel soon, I'm sure. If
you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, feed this puffer a star
on GitHub. Star the puffer. Uh if you
want to get involved with dev, most of
which is much easier than this and a lot
more enjoyable. Discord is right here.
Other than that, you can follow me on X
for more content, including articles you
can't find anywhere else. So, thank you
very much and I will be back.